[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález bolivia dio
inicio a la campaña presidencial para
los comicios del próximo 18 de octubre
la persona que sea elegida será el
encargado o la encargada de suceder a
evo morales y a un gobierno interino en
medio de un país ampliamente polarizado
con muchos problemas económicos ante la
amenaza también del avance de la
pandemia de kobe 19 pero sobre todo con
un gran malestar por parte de los
ciudadanos hacia el estado como
institución hacia las instituciones
públicas y hacer las propuestas que
están haciendo algunos de los candidatos
una campaña presidencial inédita porque
es una campaña virtual debido
precisamente a la pandemia del cobi 19
esta campaña inédita es nuestro tema de
debate hoy en france 24 para analizar lo
hemos invitado a barinas exiliadas a
ellas analista política económica y
consultora del banco mundial nos atiende
desde la ciudad de la paz también está
con nosotros manuel saavedra dirigente
del partido alianza juntos en el
departamento de santa cruz según esta
conversación desde la capital de ese
departamento
las ciudades de santa cruz de la sierra
en el oriente boliviano y rené orellana
ex ministro de planificación durante el
gobierno del ex presidente evo morales
hace parte del movimiento al socialismo
más también es sociólogo y tiene un
doctorado en antropología jurídica él se
encuentra en la ciudad de cochabamba
cubrimos las tres ciudades más
importantes de bolivia la paz cochabamba
y santa cruz también queremos conocer su
opinión y sus preguntas pueden unirse a
este debate a esta conversación a través
de las redes sociales en twitter no se
encuentran como arroba france24 guión al
piso s
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal ahí
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios con
la etiqueta numeral el debate
efe 124 tenemos el tema tenemos los
invitados quiero comenzar preguntándole
a rené orellana en la ciudad de
cochabamba
lo primero que uno pensaría después de
los antecedentes y en lo que ha vivido
bolivia a lo largo de este último año es
si hay garantías para estas elecciones
presidenciales para el 18 de octubre
rené orellana adelante
muchas gracias santiago a usted a los
invitados a los presentes a todos los
que nos ven y nos escuchan es una
pregunta muy importante hemos hemos
visto que las reelecciones se han
postergado varias veces hemos vivido
meses muy muy difíciles en bolivia y el
contexto de estas de estos meses debería
ayudarnos a responder su pregunta estos
meses han sido meses de una caída de la
economía del empleo
lo siento el desempleo
estábamos en 4.3 hoy estamos sobre el 10
por ciento hay una desazón en la gente
porque se han bajado los ingresos hay un
proceso de desnutrición y subnutrición
agobiante en los niños y jóvenes se ha
perdido la educación estos meses desde
octubre del año pasado nos vivió una una
ofensiva muy dura del gobierno de
jeanine áñez con dos masacres y
asesinatos como los ha definido la
oficina del alto comisionado de derechos
humanos la señora bachelet
interamericana de derechos humanos un
régimen que además ampara paramilitares
y eso ha creado un ambiente muy difícil
para el proceso electoral hay una
persecución política a los que se
considera de oposición hay un ambiente
de racismo de polarización de represión
del estado un lenguaje muy duro de
persecución han habido denuncias de
torturas se ha hecho el propio comisión
de derechos humanos y este es el
ambiente de fin de elecciones y manuel
su opinión en la ciudad de santa cruz de
la sierra hay garantías para desarrollar
y llevar a cabo estos comicios
presidenciales necesarios para darle
estabilidad política a este país
suramericano
muy buenas noches santiago muchas
gracias por la invitación gusto de
saludarlo bien sin duda alguna el país
está atravesando por momentos por
momentos muy duros muy difíciles pero
porque estamos en esta situación los
bolivianos porque lastimosamente hace
casi un año sufrimos un fraude un fraude
que fue certificado por organismos
internacionales la bea de representantes
de la comunidad europea también así lo
certificaron y de ahí para adelante
surgieron una serie de dificultades en
lo político en lo social el país se tuvo
que pacific para pacificar prácticamente
porque habían indicio había gente del
más que ya planteaba una posible guerra
civil a partir de ese momento se convoca
elecciones e iniciamos la pandemia el
coronavirus y debido a esta pandemia
tenemos que ir posponiendo las
elecciones que estaban programadas para
mayo inicialmente ahora estamos
prácticamente en septiembre y ya tenemos
una fecha definida para el 18 de octubre
han habido intentos por parte del
movimiento al socialismo de no
garantizar esa seguridad teniendo unas
elecciones que puedan transcurrir en un
estado de derecho en un estado con las
condiciones para que se puedan llevar
adelante
-recientemente santiago
un bloqueo perverso en media pandemia no
se puede entender cómo se puede plantear
esta situación inclusive ya hay gente
que está siendo procesada por parte del
estado de instituciones del país que son
afines al movimiento al socialismo
murieron 40 personas porque esos
bloqueos impidieron que les llegue el
oxígeno el más se dio cuenta el grave
error político y el precio político que
esto le estaba significando y tuvieron
que retroceder en esa medida y a partir
de ahí se viabilizó y se consolidó la
fecha del 18 de octubre para las
próximas elecciones nacionales nosotros
tenemos la confianza y la fe que esta
fecha ya es definitiva y que podremos ir
por cien los bolivianos a las urnas para
elegir un gobierno democrático en la paz
varinia a cecilia das a otra de nuestras
invitadas marinas de ahí queda sobre la
mesa un poco el panorama político sobre
todo estos dos espectros políticos
y completamente opuestos allí en bolivia
desde su perspectiva desde su análisis
si hay garantías para estas elecciones y
repito esta pregunta y se la hago a los
tres invitados porque en el proceso
electoral anterior quedó en entredicho
la institucionalidad las autoridades los
partidos los candidatos y los ciudadanos
quedaron más confundidos que con un
panorama político claro ya vemos las
consecuencias de eso un año después
bueno muy buenas noches santiago muy
buenas noches a todos a todos nuestros
oyentes también yo creo que la única
forma de lograr una democracia es
alcanzando la con un voto y con unas
elecciones libres plurales e inclusivas
no podemos hablar de unas elecciones
democráticas en bolivia si no tenemos
una inclusión si no tenemos una
pluralidad y no si no son libres y son
sobre todo verificables y
transparentes yo creo que bolivia a
lamentablemente estos últimos años y
sobre todo desde el año pasado lleva
pagando un precio alto sobre un
prorroguismo que está destruyendo el
país este prorroguismo se hace carne
primero con el presidente evo morales
que terminamos en en octubre del año
pasado
si te termina saliendo del país y ahora
la señora áñez también está tentada a
quedarse en un prorroguismo en el
gobierno éste prorroguismo está
destruyendo el país así pierde mucha
credibilidad al interior y al exterior
de bolivia perdemos mucha credibilidad
como bolivianos y un gobierno
transitorio que solamente estaba llamado
a hacer las elecciones ha pospuesto dos
veces las elecciones en mayo y el 6 de
septiembre por razones por la pandemia
pero también una razón que se puede
comprobar
que hablar con la verdad y con los
hechos si la intencionalidad de
debilitar el partido que estaba
liderizando las encuestas
se ha contratado es de reconocimiento de
todos que se ha contratado que el
gobierno ha contratado una empresa de
lobbistas internacional y que hace
marketing político no es la primera vez
que se utiliza marketing político en
bolivia lamentablemente ya somos hasta
famosos con un filme con sandra bullock
en un marketing político que se que se
usó en bolivia en el 2002
si estás todas estos hechos en los
cuales me estoy refiriendo ponen en duda
ponen una credibilidad de lo que es y
necesitan bolivia unas elecciones
transparentes creíbles para recuperar la
democracia para recuperar la
credibilidad y sobre todo para recuperar
la estabilidad que necesita bolivia en
medio de una pandemia mundial donde no
se está impactando en el tema económico
y en el tema de salud y reme en la
ciudad de cochabamba
tomando un poco las palabras que nos
dice que nos dice varinia cecilia daza
y la alternancia esa necesidad de no
prorrogarse en el poder cree usted que
tal vez darle alternancia entre los
partidos darle el bastón a otra
formación política podría darle entonces
un poco de estabilidad a este país dado
el escenario que hay
por supuesto ese es el objetivo de las
elecciones pero sobre todo nuestro nivel
de hill
el tejido de solidaridad de apoyo mutuo
la división que se ha creado
artificiosamente en todo que es
importante identificarlo en santiago se
ha dicho que esos indígenas y campesinos
que se movilizaron y se movilizan así
como los médicos que están hoy en las
calles nos llevan cuatro o cinco meses
sin sueldo 500 médicos y muchos más que
están pasando hambre que no tienen
educación sus hijos porque este gobierno
que tenemos ahora les clausuró el año
escolar es el único país en américa la
tiene que hacer acá 21 del año escolar
hay dos indicadores que yo te sugiero
ponerlos en la mesa que quiero
dramáticos tenemos un señor presidente
un comité cívico en una parte de bolivia
que llama a esos indígenas bestias luego
corrige y dice monstruos que no piensan
tenemos una masacre en senkata en el
alto que con el pretexto de que dicen
que iba a haber una guerra civil agarrar
a un niño que se llama kevin calle rauch
un niño que estaba caminando por la
calle con sus dos hermanitos un niño
discapacitado
lo agarran en medio de las torturas y
los torturan a sus hermanos
la señora michelle bachelet en su
reporte reporta 28 personas que han sido
sometidas a electrocución y asfixia con
bolsas de plástico
ese es el desastre que revela la marca
de este gobierno llamado de transición
que nosotros lo llamamos golpista que
con el pretexto el fraude y ha propuesto
esto que creo que es importante decirlo
en santiago ojalá haya un programa sobre
esto hay cuatro reportes de entidades
científicas con 13 expertos en temas de
estadísticas electorales que han dicho
que no hubo fraude
que el fraude fue el informe preparado
premeditadamente para armar la narrativa
del fraude esta es un tema que hay que
discutirlo necesitamos una auditoría
independiente se quemaron 23 por ciento
de las actas qué casualidad en los
lugares justamente donde el más tenía
grandes posibilidades de ghana fue una
estrategia aquí preparada pero más allá
de eso ni si ese hecho político no puede
justificar que nuestro país sea
destruido socialmente culturalmente en
su tejido de unidad entre campos duda
entre indígenas y nos eligen as más allá
lo que está pasando con nuestra economía
que nuestra economía está en un estado
calamitoso porque este gobierno no la ha
sabido manejar hoy ha dicho el ministro
de economía el señor ortiz que tenemos
un déficit de 2 mil 900 millones de
dólares porque no supieron manejar la
economía entonces es urgente y lo dice
es muy bien santiago
una salida democrática necesitamos un
gobierno responsable que sepa manejar el
país volviera a unirnos y volver a
reconciliarnos
manuel saavedra en santa cruz de la
sierra su opinión necesaria la
alternancia ustedes se prometen en un
mandato presidencial darle orden por fin
a este país
sin duda alguna y el inicio de todo esto
se dio en función a no respetar esa
alternancia el gobierno del más y evo
morales- plantear un referéndum y esto
es un poco esto es bueno explicarlo para
que la gente se pueda dar cuenta lo que
pasó en bolivia plantearon un referéndum
para que él puede ser reelecto una vez
más que ya constitucionalmente no podía
hacerlo y hemos morales y el más perdió
es el referéndum como en bolivia se
vivió un proceso de
desinstitucionalización se perforaron
todos los poderes del estado el machismo
lleva morales consiguieron persuadir al
tribunal constitucional para que lo
habilite pasando por encima del
referéndum y del voto de los ciudadanos
a partir de ese escenario ya hubo un
quiebre un quiebre en la
institucionalidad y en el cumplimiento
de las normas pero más allá de eso
fuimos a elecciones ya con un nuevo
morales como candidato ilegal y
perdieron las elecciones pero al no
aceptar eso hicieron el fraude eso está
más que verificado hay la comunidad
europea las personas que estuvieron
presentes la oea si lo ha certificado
pero a partir de ahí empezamos a vivir
una situación muy complicada
el vídeo y me gustaría que usted lo
pueda poner en algún momento de un nuevo
morales después de que de que pierde el
país si tiene que huir convocando desde
mexico por teléfono filmado a que se
acerquen las ciudades para que no llegue
el alimento y la gente sufra de hambre
como puede hacer eso una persona que ama
a su país que ama a los ciudadanos no se
entiende en esa situación pero posterior
a eso empieza ya a un bloqueo
sistemático a través de la asamblea
legislativa que en este momento tener en
bolivia que tenemos en bolivia que tiene
mayoría masista que debemos ser el único
en el mundo donde hay recursos de la
cooperación internacional más de 1500
millones de dólares disponibles para ser
usados para combatir el coronavirus para
reactivar la economía y no los podemos
usar porque los asambleístas del más
están obstinados en bloquearlos en no
permitir que se usen esos esos recursos
y posterior a eso lo que yo le comentaba
un bloqueo en media pandemia bloqueo de
camino no permiten que lleguen los
alimentos no permiten que el oxígeno
mueren 40 personas por no poder respirar
ese es un escenario terriblemente
preocupante y que lógicamente partió
desde la falta de la capacidad de pensar
en salir del poder en dar continuidad a
otras personas y lastimosamente el
prójimo no ha hecho mucho daño y vemos
que el 18 esto termine y podamos tener
un gobierno electo marín ya a cecilia en
la ciudad de la paz el tema de la
polarización preocupa mucho a la
comunidad internacional la división
social que hay en bolivia en torno a los
temas políticos esto puede ser una
piedra en el zapato para llevar a estos
comicios a un buen puerto si los
resultados son muy reñidos y muy
cercanos como fue el escenario de las
elecciones pasadas puede generar hay más
conflicto el tema de la polarización
como lo vio usted
por supuesto santiago tú mismo te acabas
de dar cuenta tú mismo estás escuchando
lo que estaba mencionando los dos
panelistas que tienen porque son
completamente diferentes entre los demás
estoy yo solamente estoy escuchando una
polarización que en el pasado antes de
la salida de evo morales estaba
alimentada por el gobierno también de
alguna forma y hoy día seguimos viviendo
esta política de polarización y ahora
alimentada por el actual gobierno de
trànsit de transición si un gobierno
transitorio que polariza mucho más
estamos escuchando que han habido
bloqueo la gente bloque en bolivia
porque se muere de hambre la gente está
sufriendo hambre la gente está
utilizando sus recursos para comer y
para para poder comprar algún tipo de
medicamentos
el gobierno de transición tenía dos
mandatos claros en bolivia a nombre de
la democracia si en un por supuesto
fraude que todavía está en tela de
juicio todavía se está investigando y yo
no tengo ningún elemento de hecho que me
permita afirmar rotundamente hoy en día
que ha habido fraude electoral en
bolivia todavía estamos en proceso de
investigación de ese tema entonces no
podemos utilizar esos temas para
polarizar más la gente si no va a servir
es unas elecciones donde no tengas
candidatos donde no estén incluidos los
pueblos indígenas donde no se tenga en
cuenta los movimientos sociales donde no
se tenga en cuenta la los bulls la gente
vulnerable la gente desfavorecida no nos
va a llegar no nos va a llevar a una
democracia sana una raya estable a una
estabilidad como país que hoy día
necesitamos
si es racismo el odio está alimentado y
siempre fue alimentado por los gobiernos
no solamente en bolivia pasa también en
los eeuu lo estamos viendo con la con la
muerte de este muchacho no sí sí claro
que es también racismo que es también
odio entonces que debemos hacer
tenemos que tratar hoy en día más que
nunca y con esto termino si mi
intervención es hoy en día necesitamos
una bolivia que camine por el centro
pero cuán difícil es para el ser humano
caminar por el centro es mucho más fácil
siempre andarse por las esquinas
luego la ronda y sigo con manuel en la
ciudad de santa cruz
le pregunto sobre las prioridades que
debe tener ese gobierno que se ha
elegido a partir del 18 hago esta
pregunta adelantando un poco al futuro y
al escenario que venga a partir de esa
fecha porque es que las aristas y los
problemas de este país son múltiples son
muchos los temas que hay a tratar
para el mandatario la mandataria la
persona que llegue a liderar el destino
de bolivia no va a ser un gobierno fácil
cuál debe ser la prioridad
tenemos la pandemia la crisis económica
la crisis social la polarización
son muchos las aristas cualquiera de
usted
bien solo aclarar un tema porque la
panelista anterior afirmaba que en
bolivia se bloquea porque la gente tiene
hambre sería interesante y me gustaría
que venga al país y vea lo que está
pasando en realidad sabe usted cuál fue
el motivo del bloqueo de ese bloqueo
perverso donde murieron 40 personas
modificar las elecciones que ellos no
querían que se modifique la fecha de
elecciones ese fue el motivo central del
bloqueo ellos querían que sea de
septiembre y no aceptaban que se
modifica el 18 de octubre no entendían
que la fecha no era segura y eso lo
determinaron los epidemiólogos los
científicos los que entienden de cómo
combatir la enfermedad ese fue el motivo
por eso es que sería bueno me gustaría
que de repente pueda visitarnos y pueda
ver lo que pasa en bolivia y por otro
lado las elecciones están garantizadas
para todos para los indígenas para los
campesinos para la gente que vive en
ciudades en ese sentido las próximas
elecciones del 18 de octubre no van
excluir a nadie
y por si acaso en bolivia el voto es
obligatoria entonces todos tienen que ir
a votar así es el sistema boliviano por
otro lado lo que usted me preguntaba
el país y el mundo después de la
pandemia
va a tener que va a tener grandes
dificultades para salir adelante y eso
no nos excluye a los bolivianos
lógicamente los desafíos están ahí lo
que es clave es poder reactivar la
economía generar empleos proteger a los
empleos creados y se han empezado a
implementar algunos programas por parte
del gobierno yo le quiero dar algunos
datos también que son interesantes
cuando el más de el gobierno había un
déficit fiscal de cerca del 97 por
ciento en cerca de tres meses hasta
febrero antes de la pandemia el actual
gobierno lo disminuyó a cerca de siete
puntos
estamos hablando casi tres puntos y eso
es porque se estaba haciendo una
administración eficiente hubo una época
de despilfarro tal vez nosotros los
bolivianos desaprovechamos la mejor
década que nos podría haber pasado y
lastimosamente no solucionar lo
solucionamos los problemas de
infraestructura los problemas de base
como país se abandonó un sistema de
salud durante 14 años y lastimosamente
en esta pandemia
hemos visto la falta que hacía invertir
en salud
el propio presidente morales en su
momento dijo que era más importante
construir canchas que construir
hospitales
y ese precio lo estamos pagando en este
momento lastimosamente y rené su opinión
cuál debe ser la prioridad para sacar
este país adelante
bueno primero se dice mucho que en
bolivia hubo despilfarro y es eso se ha
convertido en una consigna casi todos
los días las vi como haber despilfarro
si logramos bajar el desempleo 4.3 por
ciento y estamos cerca del 12 por ciento
la pobreza extrema cayó de 38 por ciento
a 15 por ciento
teníamos bonos para las madres para los
niños
teníamos producción tenemos estabilidad
y él decide al que se refiere el señor
eso se llama un éxito expansivo es un
decir basado en inversión pública estaba
planificado en el plan de desarrollo
económico y social hasta el 2020 22 y el
partir de 2022 empezaron a ingresar los
recursos producto del proceso
industrialización y las exportaciones es
que la economía hay que planificarla no
hay que manejarla con ccoo
hay que hacer medidas rápidas inmediatas
tenemos que el tema alimentario que
tenemos que alimentar a nuestros niños
hay que retomar la educación se ha
clausurado el sistema educativo vitral
ya eso no debe hacerse ni siquiera haití
ha clausurado el año escolar han privado
a nuestros niños de las escuelas los que
estaban 1º de primaria
ahora ya no sabrán leer ni escribir bien
y tendrán nociones de matemática básica
de aritmética es un daño muy grave lo
que se ha hecho a esto en acción su
nivel llama la catástrofe generacional
porque porque no pudo
a través de la cocción virtual y la
educación a distancia necesitamos
reconstruir el tejido nacional hay que
concertar hay que sentarnos con los
diferentes hay que volver a construir
hermandad somos un país unido por eso
nos llamamos estado plurinacional hay
que hacer inversiones masivas en
infraestructura rápidamente a través de
los municipios transferir recursos a los
municipios en mover gas menores generar
empleo en una perspectiva inmediata para
atacar el desempleo hay que desarrollar
un programa de alimentación a través de
las escuelas están desnutridos e iu sus
nutrientes a nuestros niños y mendigos
cada vez más en la calle está creciendo
la pobreza extrema en termas grandes
estructurales hay que renegociar la
deuda externa no lo ha hecho este
gobierno debió haberlo hecho rápidamente
apenas comenzó la pandemia porque eso
nos va a dar oxígeno financiero si
logramos una negociación que nos permita
no pagar servicios de deuda estos
próximos tres años vamos a tener en tres
dólares de disponibilidad libre que hay
que invertirlos en educación
hay que concluir con los hospitales que
estaban construyendo hay que invertir
obviamente en procesos productivos la
segura alimentaria es muy importante hay
que invertir nuestros proyectos
estratégicos no se van a dar dividen
divisas en el futuro electricidad para
exportación petroquímica litio hay que
invertir en economía el conocimiento
estas son las áreas que son parte de
nuestro programa tenemos un plan
inmediato y tenemos un plan de mediano y
largo plazo y ya lo hicimos tenemos un
candidato que fue precisamente economía
y nos sacó de la crisis varinia aquí hay
un personaje muy importante en el
escenario político boliviano y es evo
morales- él se encuentra en la ciudad de
buenos aires en argentina después de
haber dejado el país ante el escenario
que se presentó después de las
elecciones ya veíamos acá señal de
fraude él dejó el país se fue a méxico
ahora está en argentina que tanta
injerencia puede tener evo morales en
estos comicios ahora que le han dicho
que no puede participar en ningún tipo
de cargo público después de que las
instituciones bolivianas
le dieran esa orden
bueno evo morales es un presidente que
ha estado casi 14 años en el poder 25
años dentro de la estructura de gobierno
tanto en diputada con en la asamblea
plurinacional el parlamento entonces
después de un gobierno tiene muchos
seguidores internamente de bolivia y
creo que ha sido donde los pocos
presidentes y siempre que reconocer con
la verdad ha sido uno de los pocos
presidentes de bolivia que se lo conoce
en cada rincón del planeta a mí me tocó
visitar países en áfrica así dentro de
las posiciones que de trabajo
profesionales y en un país remoto como
jim y en conakry
el presidente alpha condé se refería a
evo morales
estoy hablando muchas personas
seguramente no saben dónde está con aquí
sí
y eso es un hecho eso es un hecho que no
lo podemos borrar o tapar con el dedo
por otro lado se ha vuelto un personaje
controversial que ahora produce
incomodidad en el contexto internacional
y nacional también también gracias a un
marketing político y algo que ella como
mujer estoy totalmente contraria
totalmente me opongo y soy muy enfática
en eso en la utilización de la mujer
para crear un marketing político en
denigrar y en utilizar a la gente a la
mujer en ningún caso eso no se puede
hacer y ningún periodista pues debería
hacerlo si eso es inaceptable
manuel chaves santa cruz de la sierra le
hago la misma pregunta también ustedes
en su bancada política alguna ingerencia
una presencia colaboración en algún tipo
de desestabilización como ya lo han
señalado allí varios medios en bolivia
por parte del ex presidente evo morales
bien sin duda alguna él lo ha intentado
y que un presidente se ha conocido no
significa que sea un buen presidente las
personas pueden ser conocidas porque son
buenas porque son malas islr fue muy
conocido está bien también
necesariamente fueron muy buenas
personas pero volviendo un poco al tema
de morales ha intentado desestabilizar
al actual gobierno y lo ha hecho peor
todavía en medio de una pandemia todos
esos actos de presos lo que es lo que yo
le comenté más ahora hay una acusación
que está pez que pesa sobre el sobre una
presunta relación con menor de con
menores de edad han afectado y el más
con evo sin evo morales
ha disminuido su aceptación o su
intención de voto esos números
históricos que tenía el máximo en las
propias encuestas que conocemos ahora
del 60 del 50 por ciento se han reducido
a casi la mitad en este momento el más
tiene una intención de voto de cerca del
25 por ciento eso está muy lejos de lo
que tenía y es por algo es porque la
gente se ha dado cuenta de que con las
acciones que ha venido haciendo no está
ayudando al país es más está lo está
perjudicando y una persona que quiere
representar lo que nos representó que
esté
tipo de actitudes pues al final les
motiva a que se lo apoye y eso se
refleja en la intención de voto de los
ciudadanos
rené en la ciudad de cochabamba una de
las críticas y de los señalamientos que
hacían durante el mandato del ex
presidente evo morales es que llevaba
mucho tiempo en el poder no daba espacio
a la alternancia y tampoco que había un
heredero político claro para poder
continuar con ese proyecto socialista
que él quería implementar quiso
implementar durante su gobierno en
bolivia
quien puede relevar porque aquí tenemos
a luis arse como candidato pero es
verdaderamente hace un heredero de todo
el capital político que tiene evo
morales- allí en bolivia es el verdadero
heredero del exmandatario
y yo creo que no se hereda a una
obligación de
y dirigir y conducir más aún en momentos
tan difíciles como los que te
en bolivia vamos a tener una tarea muy
dura muy dura y hay que poner en acción
nuestros mejores técnicos conocimientos
y capacidades el más es un instrumento
político surge de los movimientos
sociales tiene una larga historia en los
movimientos sociales y eso que llaman
las marchas y los bloqueos se
protagonizan históricamente siempre en
bolivia el más nace del lado de las
organizaciones campesinas indígenas de
las marchas por la vida en los años 90
cuando se lucha contra la privatización
del agua sigue extracción del gas
entonces son los movimientos y las
organizaciones sociales las que le dan
el respaldo y las que postulan a una
persona y ahí le han dado sus espaldas
compañero luís arts
el economista lucharse al hermano de
abby choquehuanca es una dupla
importante un economista con un
compañero que es david que tiene una
visión muy clara del desarrollo en
armonía con la madre tierra ha promovido
la resolución del día de la madre tierra
en naciones unidas o isla er se celebra
el 22 de marzo en el mundo el día de la
madre tierra
ya me quedan pocos minutos para cerrar
el programa quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones voy a comenzar por varinia
en la paz
en 50 segundos cuál es el escenario que
viene después del 18 desde su punto de
vista no tenemos bola de cristal para
ver el futuro pero ve usted a bolivia en
el camino de la estabilización
olave otra vez convulsionada como la
vimos en octubre del año pasado como la
ve usted
hoy día vimos una noticia que por lo
menos yo la celebré mucho es que la
comunidad europea va a mandar una misión
reforzada de observación a bolivia esto
me parece fundamental en estos momentos
porque tenemos una oea que ha perdido
credibilidad al interior hay mucha
susceptibilidad dentro de bolivia sobre
el manejo que ha tenido
la única esperanza que se tiene que para
tener unas elecciones creíbles una
selección por un minuto de programa y
necesito concluir con los otros dos
invitados
y yo creo que si tenemos unas elecciones
amplias y genuinas vamos a salir
adelante vamos a lograr una estabilidad
nacional nos va a costar como a todos
los países pero bolivia va a seguir
adelante si es que lo hacemos bien y no
cometemos errores en este momento manuel
su conclusión rápidamente
se vienen tiempos muy difíciles no solo
para los bolivianos para todos los
ciudadanos del mundo con esta situación
que vivimos con lo que nos deja la
pandemia no va a ser sencillo pero los
bolivianos son un pueblo luchador y
vamos a tener unas nuevas elecciones el
18 de octubre esperemos que tengamos un
gobierno electo y sobre todo que
asumamos todas las responsabilidades que
en unidad podamos llevar adelante
nuestro país y tener mejores días
rené rápidamente
una gran oportunidad para construir un
país con en comunidad en
complementariedad y en hermandad ya no
podemos pelearnos por ser diferentes hay
que respetarnos
hay que ir juntos a la escuela juntos en
la universidad juntos a trabajar si hay
que reconstruir nuestro estado
plurinacional y lo tenemos que hacer
todos unidos ese es el mensaje que nos
deja este momento a los tres muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en el debate de france 24 ustedes
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas en las redes sociales
gracias
[Música]